spécialiste du Moyen Orient, le
journaliste Christian Chenost,
qui vient de publier Qatar: lesr
ce pays.
beaucoup d'être avec nous.
Voezezezez nous aider
à comprendre un peu ce qu'est
le Qatar, ce que veut le Qatar.
esesesesesesesesesesesesesesese,
quand même, pour les
travailleurs étrangers?
On l'a vu dans le reportage.
CHRISTIAN CHESNOT, reporter,
- Ah! Bien, c'est le prix
du sang, c'est le prix de
la sueur, hein. Il faut savoir
que le Qatar a importé 1 million
de travailleurs principale
de l'Afrique sur la dernière
décennie, et c'est ces
qu'on a retrouvés sur
les chantiers de la Coupe
du monde. Ce ndedededededededed,
c'est les routes, les ponts,
l'aéroportorororort, le métro,
le tramway. Et donc, c'est
des gens, effectivement,
qui t t t t t t t t t t t t t tt
60 heures par semaine.
nsnsnsns des conditions
assez terribles.
- Bien oui, terribles,AlAlAlAlAu
des améliorations, hein, parce
que... effectivement, il y avait
des pressions internationales,
d'Amnistie, de la presse,
du compte, ils se sont dit :
"Il faut quand même faire
quelque chose compte tenu de
l'impact de la Coupe du monde."
Donc, ces dernières années,
positives, notamment ils ne sont
plus payés en liquide, mais
en... par la banque. Il y a
des...
- On ne leur confisque plus
- Voilà. Voilà, mais
c'est encore... le pmemememe
c'est la loi et puis
l'application de la loi.
Le problème, c', , , , , , , , ,
ils continuent à confisquer
les passepor p p p payer
aux lance-pierres...
il y a eu une manifestation
au moi a a a a a a a a a a a a t
manifesté parce qu'ils étaient
yéyéyéyés depuis six mois.
Bon, résultat : ils ont été
à l'avion en 48 heures.c'c'c'c'e
quatarien, donc?
- Oui. Il ne faut pas oublier.
Il y a toujours deux faces
de la médaille. Oui, ils sont
11 milliards de dollars
chez eux, hein, au Népal,
au Bangladesh, au Pakistan.
Donc, c'est aussi... il y a
du business derrière.
les conditions étaient presque
de l'esclavagisme moderne, hein.
Mais encore une fois, la Coupe
du monde a quand même permis
de mettre... de braquerererererr
quand même un petit peu
les choses. Et dururururs,
c'est pour ça qu'Amnistie
internationale réclame
un fonds de dedededededededededs
pour ces gens, et puis continue
de mettrrerereression après
la Coupe du monde.
- Le Qatar, il y a 20 ans,
c'iqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqi,
donc, une ascension fulgurante
grâce à tous ces gens qui ont
construit finalement.
- Ou
le projet d'un homme, cheikh
Hamad. Cheikh Hamad, c'est
le père de l'émir actuel.
Et donc, cheikh Han n n n n n n,
soit dans les sables, soit,
comment dire, pauvres et cetera.
Et donc, il renverse son père
en 95, le cheikh Khalifa,
et lui, son idée, c'est
de faire rayonner et surtout
d'utiliser la richessez,z,z,z,
le gaz offshore, la plus grande
poche au mrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtr,
bien, cette richesse, on va
l'utiliser. On va l'utiliser
pourquoi? Bien, pour se
notre pays et puis pour
rayonner et pour acheter
partout dans le monde.
- Et qu'est-ce qu'il cherchait
une reconnaissance?
l l l la reconnaissance.
Une forme de revanche aussi,
une revanche sur Dubaï, hein
il y a toujours des bisbilles
entre les émirs, hein.
Il y a des jalousies. Donc,
prendre sa revanche, rndanndannt
à l'Arabie saoudite, parce que
le Qatar a longtemps vécu
sous l'aile protectrice
de l'Arabie saoudite, heieieiei,
le Qatar c'est quoi?
C'est gtgtgtgt de sable
qui part de l'Arabie saoudite
et qui est pointé sur l'Iran.eee
indépendant, autonome,sisisisib,
un grand petit pays.
- C'est d'ailleurs lui qui cidi,
sa place le Qatar un peu dans
le monde parce que tout à coup,
tout le monde découvre un peu
ce pays-là grâioioioioioioioioi?
Un petit peu...
- Oui. C'est son premier coup
de génie, ça. Son presesesesesee
Al Jazeera, elle a été créée
en Arabie saoudite. Forcément,
elle n'a pas marché compte tenu
de la censure, et cete d d d d ,
cheikh Hamad est très malin.
Il se dit : "Tie v v v vais
récupérer cette chaîne et
en faire une sorte de CNN
arabes" etararararararararararat
dans le monde arabe et
aussi en Occident parce
qu'on découvlelelelelelelelelel,
ils peuvent parler comme nous.
Ils ont des reporters partout
dans la région. Ils sont
en Irak, en Palestine, et
cetera." Donc, de gros moyen
et on parle à tout le monde.
Donc ça... ça déjà, ça donne
lelelele à tout le monde,
y compris aux gens un peu
sulfureux, aux gens par exemplet
pas parler.
- Comme?
- Les talibans, le Hamas,
les djihadistes, notamenenenene,
et cetera. Donc, on est dans
une... dans une diplomatie,
j'allais dire, 360°. On fait
un peu comme notre pré
Macron. On fait du en même temps
tout le temps, hein. C'est-à-
on parle au Hamas, hein.
On parle aux taletetetet
on parle aux Américains.
- Et d'ailleurs, ça explique
qui ont finalement sorti
les ressssssssants étrangers
à Kaboul, quand les talibans
sont revenus.
remercié le Qatar parce qu'ils
ntntntnt aidé à sortir
les ressortissants.
Donc, tout le monde a dit :n n e
temps, le Qatar a un agenda
diplomatique qui est pas
forcément le nôtre, nous
Occidentaux, comme jsisisisisis,
le djihadisme, il y a eu
des connexions assez opaques,
hein, en Syrie, avec des gens
d'Al-Qaïdauiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiu,
on a eu malgré tout ce que
j'appelle la zone grise.
Le Qatar a investi dans l'Islam
de
en Europe.
- Donc, dans les mosquées.
- Dans les mosquées, les écoles
coraniques, les prédicateurs
acheter le Royal Monceau,
ou le peninsula, ou le PSG,
ou Balmain, ou Valentino,
c'est le business. Mais
quand on commence à toucher,
je veux dire, l'ADN des pays
en traficotant sur l'islam, là .
D'ailleurs, le président Macron
leur a tapé sur les doigts.
- Oui, parce que, là,
on s
que veut le Qatar.
- Quel est l'agenda? C'est...
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent?
Bien, de l'influence.
Ils veulent créer des réseaux
parce que, encore une fois,
c'est un tout petit pays.
On l'a dit : 300 000 habitants,
pas plus grand que la Corse.
Et puis une petite a
Donc, ils tiennent pas deuxheurà
l'Irak ou l'Arabie saoudite.
Donc, pour se protéger,dededede,
mais dans tous les domaines ;
économique, financier, sportif
culturel, éducation, partout,
pour se relier g g g g g g g g s
alliés qui, si ils ont besoin,
ils viendront à leur secours.
- Et c'est une population
qui
Les 300 000 citoyens qatariens,
ils sont extrêmement riches.
- Bien, c'est le... Ils sont
e e e e top trois mondial avec
le Luxembourg, le Liechtenstein,
c'est-à-dire, à peu près
d'habitant. Le Qatar, c'estun p.
Vous avez le PDG, qui s'appelle
l'émir; vous avez le con, , , ,t
la famille royale; et puis,
vous avez les actionnaires,
c'est les Qatariens, les
actionnaires q g g g g g g g g s
par l'État providence.
- Parce que tout est gratuit?
- Tout est gratuit.
- La
- Ah, tout, tout, tout.
Petite anecdote, je donne
le livre pour récompenser les
meilleurs... les 100 meilleurs
bacheliers, là, en j
l'émir a offert une Rolex
aux 100 meilleureleleleliers.
Donc, voilà, c'est l'opulence,
c'est la... Voilà, c'est ça.
conservateur, hein? Ça reste p .
- C'est pays bédouin un peu.
- Pour les fem d d d d d d d d ?
- Alors, les femmes, c'est pas
l'Arabie saoudite, hein.
Pendant longtemps, l'Arabie
ayayayayayayayayayayayayayayayae
pour les femmes. Le Qatar,ililis
les femmes peuvent travailler,
peuvent conduire, peuvent
mais il reste une tutelle très
forte des mâles, de la gente
masculine. C'est-à-dire qu'il
y a une sorte de "sponsoring"oy,
pour se marier, etc.
C'est une société aussi
où il y a de la polygamie.
- Ah, bien, le prince,
il a deux femmes. Son pè
il a trois femmes.
- Pourquoi cette volonté
de tenc'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'c'ci
n'a pas de tradition de football
t?t?t?t?
- Aucune, aucune. Le sport,
là-bas, c'est les courses
de chevaux et la chasse aux
faucons. Pour eux, c'est...
je vais dire, le Graal
du "soft power", c'est-à-dire
Hein, on est 8 milliards
sur Terre. Vous avez peut-être
4 milliards de personnes qui
donc, c'est un formidable coup
de projecteurs sur ce
encore, vous l'avez dit,
il y a 20 ans, qui connaissait
Personne. Donc, le pari
est réussi. Maintenant,
tout le monde connaît le Qatar,
tout le monde parle du Qatar.
Parfois en mal, parfois en bien,
sur la carte du monde.
- Est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas
fallu quand même boycotter
cette Coupe du monde?gigigigigi,
c'est la FIFA. C'est la FIFA,
donc, l'organisation qui gère
ce mondial au Qatar.
La France qui va aussi favoriser
le
à l'époque, c'est lui
qui va aamamamamener des voix
africaines pour qu'il voté
pour le Qatar.
les femmes, les LGBT,
l'environnement,
les travailleurs, le climat.
Pourquoi la FIFA donne la Coupe
du monde à un pa. . . . . . . .,
deux, trois ans après, on va v "
Voilà. Donc, il y a une immenset
autour de ça.
de la FIFA, Gianni Infantino,
où est-ce qu'il habite
À Lausanne? À Genève?
Non, il habite maintenant
à Doha avec sa faeueueueueueueu,
au moment où ça se passe,
de dire : "Ah onononon,
c'est pas bien le boycott."
Bien non, c'est trop tard.
Il fal
- Mais peut-être que ces grands
évtstststs sportifs, maintenant
c'est ce genre de pays qui va
pouvoir se les payer, non?
opopopopopopopopopopopopopopopoe
que c'est tout à fait vrai.Je p,
les grandes compétitions
en Occident, en Europe,
aux Éninininis, au Canada,
il y en aura toujours,
mais c'est vrai que le Golfe et
l'As
de plus en plus de ces
compétitions. L'Arabie saoudite,
hein, quiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqi.
Le Qatar, qui rêve d'organiser
les lylylylympiques d'étéenenen,
il sont en train de travailler
sur le dossier. Donc, voilà,
ils vont... parce que l'argent,
parce que mae e e e e e e e e e,
l'argent achète tout.
- Alors,n'n'n'n'y serez pas
parce que vous êtes interdit
de séjour.
- momomomomomomomomomomomomomome
j'ai écrit quelques livres p p c
mon collègue du "Figaro",
Georges Malbrunot. Moi,
j'y serai pas, mai
un objet assez fascinant,
parce que c'est un jeu de miroir
aussi sur cette mondialisation,
sur ces nouvelles puissances
émergentes, sur nous...-ê-ê-ê-êt
au Canada, vous êtes le nouveau
moaiaiaiais nous, l'Europe,
on est un peu en déclin
et là-bas il y a beaucoupdedede,
on l'a dit l'environnement.
Alors, est-ce que c'était
très... "green" d'organiser
une Coup
Non. Et en même temps,
les Qatariens disent : "Oui,
mais nos stades sont climatisés
avec de l'énergie solaire."
une concentration de toutes
les questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui.
Voilà, donc, il y a tout ça!
-